(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Yeah, right, what would
be the biggest pet peeve?
- The biggest pet peeve, I mean,
you're getting into my car, my home,
my sanctuary, the last
thing I want you to do
is leave trash in my car.
- Oh! Yeah yeah yeah.
- I don't like when
they think I don't know
they spilled their drink in the back.
- Mmm-hmm
- (laughs) because I know.
- Try to clean it up.
- If there's a ride six to 10 minutes
and you are adamant about
the right way to go,
I'm like, I'm pretty
sure that you're gonna
still get there in six to 10 minutes.
- Yeah exactly.
- You know what I mean, like
- Take this way, take that way
- Yeah
- This is pretty good.
- My pet peeve is someone that eats
at least without asking.
If you go to someone's
house that you've met
for the first time.
Do you just open up a bag of
chips and eat over their rug?
- (laughs)
- I had a passenger come
in to the passenger side
with a plate of cake.
- (laughs)
- As we were driving, just
eating it with their hands.
- Their hands?
- With their hands,
- No fork?
- Yeah, just right there.
- What are you savages?
- Yeah
(laughs)
- When you pick up a bunch of drunk people
and they want you to stop
at a fast food place.
- Oh yeah! Like Jack in the Box.
- Yeah
- I've had that.
- And its like two in the morning.
You pick up a bunch of drunk people.
- Yeah
- And they're like can
we stop at Mcdonalds?
- And also just some of
the sound effects too.
Someone just came in and it
wasn't very late at night
and they had an apple.
And I knew they had an apple.
(crunching sound effect)
- They're letting you
know with every bite.
- (crunching sound effect)
- Did you ever get hit on?
You must get hit on a lot.
- Oh yeah, all the time. Yeah.
- Most women, I would say,
you know, don't hit on
them at the workplace.
- I don't like that.
- Yeah
- I always let passengers know.
- Oh!
- I don't like when you
ask me for my phone number.
- It's not a dating service.
- (laughs) It's not a dating service. No.
- The strangest thing for me
is getting hit on in a pool.
If you're gonna hit on
me, get your own ride.
Okay, get your own ride to hit on me.
- I had one Uber passenger that
said he liked female drivers
'cause he would like
to look at their legs.
- Oh my god, yeah that sounds right.
- If there's no one else in my car
and then they automatically
sit in the passenger seat.
- Oh yeah.
- I'm like come on now.
Like I drive a Yaris.
- When someone gets in
my car and gets up front.
I only have a problem with it
if you don't speak the whole ride.
- Okay
- Like imagine if you're
driving and I got in,
I say, hi, how are you?,
- (laughs) that's exactly
- I think the best part about it
is when I ask them so
why do you sit up front?
'cause occasionally I will ask
them why people sit up front.
They'll be like, well I feel
weird sitting in the back.
And I go, well why?
Do you get motion sickness?
No. I just feel like you're
driving me somewhere.
- I have had plenty of fart
passengers farting in my car.
They fart when the windows are up to.
I'm like roll the window
down then pass the gas.
- This is one.
If someone is playing music.
They will reach out and
they will twist them
and they will turn.
- Oh god. (laughs)
- They will fiddle with the stereo.
Like this one really drunk guy,
he was like leaving the bar
and he was like turning it up.
Like the bass speakers
are (choking sound effect)
- Yeah like I'm crushing you.
- I'm turning it down.
No man, for show, for show, for show.
No, no, this is my car.
- For sure not! For surely not.
- It's not for show if
the speakers blow out.
- (laughs)
- Four stars does not mean good.
It actually means fail.
When you put five, that
means thank you for the ride.
I appreciated it.
When you put four, it means
I want you to get fired.
So, (laughs)
- Be respectful.
That's a big one.
I can't stand when no
one says thank you to me.
I'm like you're welcome, alright,
like I just drove you somewhere
and no thank you for that.
(both laughs)
- A lot of the times,
let's say a passenger's right off the bat
like pissed or something like that.
I'll pick them up and they'll be like,
I don't know what happened,
I had another driver on its way
and then that driver canceled
so then I had to wait
five minutes for you.
And I'm like, I have no idea what happened
before your name popped up on my phone.
- So to summarize, I
would say, just be aware
that we are driving you
but we are also driving other people.
And just be courteous of other people
that are going to be in this ride.
That are going to be sharing in this car.
- No ones having the same day as you.
Like I could be on top of the world,
you know, as I pick you up.
Its like man, picking up Shelby,
like let's see where Shelby's going?
You get into the car and right off the bat
you have a problem with me.
I'm like, well geez,
like now the relationship
we could've formed is been tainted.
So its like always remember
that a driver is also a human.
We have feelings.
(upbeat music)